hello and this is Matthew from simply
learn and we're going to be covering
ansible today as one of the key tools
that you would have within your dev ops
environment so the things that we're
going to go through today is we're gonna
cover why you would want to use a
product like ansible
what ansible really is and how it's all
value to you in your organization the
differences between ansible and other
products that are similar to it on the
market and what makes ansible a
compelling product and I want to dig
into the architecture financeable going
to look at how you would create a
playbook how you'd manage your inventory
of your server environments and then
what is the actual workings of answer
Bob a little extra we're going to also
throw an anvil tower one of the secret
sauce solutions that you can use for
improving the speed and performance of
how you create your ansible environments
and finally when they go through a use
case by looking at HootSuite social
media management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as another tool that you have
within your DevOps environments for
helping manage the service and this
definitely falls on the operations side
of the dev ops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of Sam and like
yourselves Sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the service that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
Apache they could be database servers
running my sequel and if you only have a
few servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain I mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it we all love just to have
one or two servers to manage it would be
really easy Twain tain the trick however
is as we start increasing the number of
servers and this is a reality of the
environments that we live and operate in
it becomes increasingly difficult to
create consistent setup of different
infrastructures such as web servers and
databases for the simple
that were all human as if we had to
update and maintain all of those servers
by hand there's a good chance that we
would not set up each server identically
now this is where a sport really comes
to the rescue and helps you become an
efficient operations team ansible
like other system solutions such as chef
and puppet uses code that you can write
and describe the installation and set up
all of your servers so you can actually
repeat it and deploy those servers
consistently into multiple areas so now
you don't have to have one person
redoing and brief following setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
Hanceville let's step through what a
spool really is so you know this is all
great but you know how do we actually
use these tools in our environment so
ansible hat is a tool that really allows
you to create and control three key
areas that you'd have within your
operations environment first of all
there's IT automation so you can
actually write instructions that
automate the IT setup that you would
typically do manually in the past the
second is the configuration and having
consistent configuration imagine setting
up hundreds of Apache servers and being
able to guarantee with precision that
each of those Apache servers is set up
identically and then finally you want to
be able to automate the deployment so
that as you scale up your server
environment you can just push out
instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about poor configuration and how it
works with ansible so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
different environments for server farms
one is to have a key server that has all
the instructions on and then on each of
the serve
that connect to that main master server
you would have a piece of software known
as a client installed on each of those
servers that would communicate to the
main master server and then would
periodically either update or change the
configuration of the slave server this
is known as a polka figuration an
alternative is a push configuration and
the perfect configuration is slightly
different the main difference is as with
a pull configuration you have a master
server where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second rounds
where it's a push configuration server
and this contrasts with other popular
products like chef and puppet which have
a master slave architecture with a
master server connecting with a client
on a remote slave environment where you
would then be pushing out the updates
with as well you're pushing out the
service and the structure of the server
to remote hardware and you are just
putting it onto the hardware irrelevant
of the structure that's out there and
there are some significant advantages
that you have in that in that you're not
having to have the extra overhead weight
of a client installed on those remote
servers having to constantly communicate
back to the master environment so let's
step through the architecture that you
would have for an answer bowl
environment so when you're setting up a
manciple environment the first thing you
want to do is have a local machine and
the local machine is where you're gonna
have all of your instruction and really
the power of the control that you'd be
pushing out to the remote server so the
local machine is where you're gonna be
starting and doing all of your work
connected from the local machine
are all the different nodes pushing out
the different configurations that you
would set up on the local machine the
configurations that you would write and
you would write those in code
within a module so you do this on your
local machine for creating these modules
and each of these modules is actually
consistent playbooks the local machine
also has a second job and that job is to
manage the inventory of the notes you
have in your environment the local
machine is able to connect to each of
the different nodes that you would have
in your hardware network through SSH
clients or a secure client
let's take into some of the different
elements within that architecture we're
going to take a first look at play books
that you would write and create for the
ansible environments so the core of as
well is the playbook this is where you
create the instructions that you write
to define the architecture of your
hardware so the PlayBook is really just
a set of instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called Yama and this is a
standard language used for configuration
server environments did you know that
Yama actually stands for llamo eighth
markup language that's just a little
tidbit to hide behind your ear so let's
have a look or one of these play books
it looks like and here we have a sample
Yama script that we've written so you
set off your Yama script with three
dashes and that indicates the start of a
script and then the script itself is
actually consistent of two distinct
plays at the top we have play one and
below that we have played two within
each of those plays we define which
nodes are we targeting so here we have a
web server in the top play and in the
second plate we have a database server
that we're targeting and then within
each of those server environments we
have the specific tasks that we're
looking to execute so let's step through
some of these tasks we have an install
pachi tasks we have a start Apache task
and we haven't installed my sequel task
and when we do that we're going to
execute a specific set of instructions
and those instructions can include
installing Apache and then setting the
state of the Apache environments or
starting the Apache environment
and setting up and running the my sequel
environment so this really isn't too
complicated and that's the really good
thing about working with um is it's
really designed to make it easy for you
as an Operations lead to be able to
configure the environments that you want
to consistently create so let's take a
step back though we have two hosts we
have web server and database server why
do these names come from but this takes
us into our next stage and the second
part of working with ansible which is
the inventory management part of ansible
so the inventory part of answer four is
where we maintain the structure of our
network environment so what we do here
is part of the structure in creating
different nodes is we've had to create
two different nodes here we have a web
server node and a database of server net
and under web server node we actually
have the names that were actually
pointed to specific machines within that
environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the llaman
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to new services without having to
write out complex instructions so let's
have a look at how ansible actually
works in real world so the real world
environment will is that you'd have the
ansible software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your PlayBook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
SSH connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
playbook to each server and configure
that server remotely the end goal is to
have an environment
that is consistent so let's ask you a
simple question what are the major
opportunities the Ansel has over chef
and pop it really like to hear your
answers in the comments below
pop them in there and we'll get back to
you and really want to hear how you feel
at Asheville is a stronger product or
maybe you think it's a weaker product as
it compares to other similar products in
the market here's the bonus we're gonna
talk a little bit about ansible Tower so
ansible tower is an extra product that
Red Hat created that really kind of puts
the cherry on the top of the ice cream
or is the icing on your cake
Hansol all by itself is a command line
tool however as well Tower is a
framework that was designed to access
ansible
and through the ansible tower framework
we now have an easy to use GUI this
really makes it easy for non developers
to be able to create the environment
that they want to be able to manage in
their DevOps plan without having to
constantly work with the command prompt
window so instead of opening up terminal
window or a command window and writing
out complex instructions only in text
you can now use drag and drop and mouse
click actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes all right so we've
talked a lot about ansvil let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
gonna look at cut sweet
now HootSuite if you not already use
their products and they have a great
product HootSuite is a social media
management system they are able to help
with you managing your pushes of social
media content across all of the popular
social media platforms they're able to
provide the analytics they're able to
provide the tools that marketing and
sales teams can use to be able to assess
a sentiment analysis of the messages
that are being pushed out really great
tool and very popular
but part of their popularity drove a
specific problem straight to HootSuite
the chance they had at HootSuite is that
they had to constantly go back and
rebuild their server environment and
they couldn't do this continuously and
be consistent there was no standard
documentation and they had to rely on
your memory to be able to do this
consistently imagine how complex this
could get as you're scaling up with a
popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ansible wood came in
and really helped the folks over at
HootSuite today the DevOps team at
HootSuite right out play books that have
specific instructions that define the
architecture and structure of their
hardware nose and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of seconds the bottom line is
ansible has been able to provide
HootSuite with IT automation consistent
configuration and free up time from the
operations team so that instead of
managing servers they're able to provide
additional new value to the company so
here are some key takeaways we've gone
through why you'd want to have a product
such as ansible to be able to manage the
growing environment that you'd have
within your network we've looked
specifically at the three key areas of
success for ansible around IT automation
consistent configuration management and
the ability to be able to automatically
deploy new software to new servers or
even rebuild existing servers we
compared ansible from a pull and push
configuration environment how it
compares with other products such as
chef and puppet that are also popular
and used for providing a consistent and
similar service we broke down the
architecture of ansible and looked at
how the local machine really is critical
at pushing out the in
actions that you have within your
playbook that I manage within modules
and how you use the infantry to be able
to manage the actual physical hardware
available on your network finally we
looked at how you would set up a
physical ansible environment within your
network and looked at the additional
tools that are being developed by rat
hat for Hanceville including the new
asphalt our GUI interface to make it so
much easier for you to be able to build
the instructions and playbooks needed to
be able to create consistent ansible
environments and finally we looked at a
use case from HootSuite and how ansible
really help them out tremendously to
improve the efficiency of their devops
team so I hope you found this
informative give us your opinions on how
ansible competes with chef and puppet
we'd really be interested in hearing
your comments below if you liked this
video hit the subscribe button and then
follow up with the bell so you're always
getting updated on the latest videos
that we release from simply learned this
is Matthew signing off
you